jetzt willkommen zu einem weiteren video
des wohnungsumbau projektes video drei
mittlerweile und heute schauen wir uns
an was aus der wohnung werden sollen
nicht nur ich habe geplant sondern auch
viele von euch erstmal vielen dank über
350 leute haben kein eingereicht und am
ende dieses videos können ihr
entscheiden welcher der zuschauer mit
1000 euro nach hause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vorweg so ein paar grundsätzliche sachen
zu wasser und abwasser liegt da wo jetzt
gerade das bad ist es macht also für
mich relativ wenig sinn das super
aufwändig in irgendeine andere stelle zu
verlegen was gleichzeitig auch bedeutet
küche braucht er auch zu und abwasser
das bedeutet das muss alles da irgendwie
in dieser ecke bleiben das war also von
vornherein schon mal klar andererseits
will ich ja wirklich keine kosten und
mühen scheuen und bin komplett bereit
alles in sonderanfertigung zu machen
konnte deswegen komplett frei überlegen
was wie wohin soll und wie das aussehen
soll ich musste mich also nicht an
standardmaß erhalten musste nicht
schauen gibt es schränke die so und so
passen weil ich davon ausgehe dass das
alles von dem tischler für uns
angefertigt wird abseits der pläne die
ihr eingereicht haben ja auch super
viele leute verschiedene ideen bei ins
all geschickt von irgendwelchen weil
release oder irgendwelchen vorher
nachher bildern dafür auch vielen dank
und was ich ziemlich häufig gesehen habe
und wovon ich auch eigentlich
ausgegangen bin dass ich ein bauen will
printen nördlich bzw
allgemein so schönes vorne
wohnungseinrichtungen also ein bett das
wegklappen tisch der sich irgendwie
transformiert einfach sachen die
verschiedene zwecke erfüllen oder sich
wegklappen lassen um mehr platz zu haben
wir haben eben nur ungefähr 24
quadratmeter deswegen ist es eine
ziemlich smarte lösung und findet man in
beiden meiner planung wieder nach dem
ich erst mal auf papier ein bisschen
gearbeitet habe und mich grundsätzlich
damit auseinandergesetzt haben in welche
richtung das wohnungs konzept gehen soll
habe ich auch schon angefangen alles am
computer zu visualisieren mit sketchup
mit wir also als erstes modelliert und
dann mit wieder geändert also richtig
richtig weiß wie gut und wie das
funktioniert und was man da so als
neuling einfach so einsteigen kann und
folgende ideen sind dabei rausgekommen
also
idee nummer 11 habe ich quasi den
kompletten raum plan um das bad herum
gestaltet das bad muss da bleiben wo es
ist weil die wasseranschlüsse der sind
schon gehört und dort einen wohnblock
geschaffen in dem quasi alles integriert
ist was man braucht im eingangsbereich
befindet sich am bad direkt einen
einbauschrank bei dem die türen keine
tagen haben also quasi im einbauschrank
verschwinden was unheimlich clean ist
der witz daran nicht alle türen führen
in den schrank die erste tür führt durch
den schrank und ist gleichzeitig im
schrank verschwunden und eingangstür ins
bad wenn man es nicht wissen würde würde
man also gar nicht denken dass sich
dahinter noch mal im raum befindet um
dann aber noch genug platz im flur zu
haben musste ich das bad natürlich etwas
verkürzen damit den schrank dorf vor
setzen kann was aber kein besonders
großes problem ist weil wir natürlich
auf die duschwanne verzichten werden und
alles ein bisschen kleiner und kompakter
wird dusche toilette und waschbecken
habe ich genau an der wand gelassen wo
sie sind damit wir dort nicht extra
neues wasser hinlegen müssen bodentiefe
dusche schicke toilette schickes
waschbecken und vor allem eine
eingebaute ablagefläche die beleuchtet
so muss man nicht in der dusche extra
mit irgendwelchen saugnäpfen der
komischen lösung dafür finden sein
shampoo abstellen zu können sondern es
ist direkt von vornherein vernünftig
geplant und in die wand integriert was
ich mega luxuriös finden im flur wieder
an den decken wohnen einbauschränken
vorbei wo unheimlich viel stauraum ist
um hausrat und klamotten und so weiter
zu verstauen er öffnet sich der große
der große neue offene raum natürlich
habe ich die bis dato noch bestehende
wand der kirche ein gewissen und jetzt
werden viele leute sagen ja aber küche
im selben raum in dem man schläft ist
super schlecht weil es stinkt und so
weiter dafür habe ich allerdings eine
lösung wenn das bett wie ihr seht so
findet sich nicht im offenen raum
sondern lässt sich neben der küche an
die wand einklappen was bedeutet wenn
man kocht klappt man das bett einfach
weg hat einen offenen raum und vor allem
drängt das bett und der ganze kram nicht
an zu stinken die ganzen klamotten sind
im schrank verstaut und des webs ist an
die wand geklappt und kommt gar nicht
mit den gerüchen und koch dämpfen in
verbindung außerdem lohnt es sich
natürlich eine gute dunstabzugshaube zu
investieren die großen fenster hat man
auch noch ich denke also das sollte kein
problem sein und wir haben einfach zu
wenig platz um die küche in diesem raum
wirklich räumlich das bag hat allerdings
noch einen christin zugeklappten zustand
ist es nämlich nicht nur einfach
weggefahren sondern schafft platz für
den essbereich an dem bis zu vier
personen sitzen sollen können können
sollen so an der unterseite des brettes
also ein klapptisch befestigt neben dem
auch noch klappt spielplatz finden was
mega meisters zum einen natürlich cool
weil man mit mehreren leuten dann in der
wohnung zusammen essen kann und zum
anderen schafft man dort platz der
eigentlich so ein bisschen in der kirche
fehlt weil die küche so wie es jetzt
geplant habe natürlich schon ziemlich
klein ansonsten befindet sich in dem
offenen raum unter der fensterfläche
dann noch ein kleines sofa ein teppich
ein beistelltisch und ein fernseher der
mit einer wandhalterung an der wand
festgemacht ist damit man auch aus dem
bett fernseh schauen kann und den
fernseher einfach dahin dreht wo man ihn
haben will das bedeutet werden mit
diesem plan ziemlich einfach stauraum
geschaffen ein schickes neues aber
kleines bad eine kleine küche ein
ausklappbares red ein sofa ein
wohnbereich ein essbereich im prinzip
finde ich diesen plan schon ziemlich
perfekt auf der anderen seite ist er
vielleicht nicht frisch genug und ich
hätte gerne noch irgendwas spezielleres
bevor wir dazu aber kommen erstmal die
frage geklärt wie ich überhaupt von
überall aus und diese pläne machen kommt
kein problem dank meines kemmer sized
lgs 66 vielen von euch wird msi mit
sicherheit ein begriff sein sie sind
einer der führenden entwickler und
hersteller von it produkten und es gibt
sie schon seit über 35 jahren für die
leute hier auch noch nicht wissen dass
msi ausmacht erzähle ich es euch jetzt
obwohl msi häufig und auch
richtigerweise mit gaming in verbindung
gebracht wird haben sie natürlich
unheimlich leistungsstarken laptops ins
liegt im design für kreative
anwendungsbereich genau so was wie ich
immer die self reihe verbindet also
höchste gaming power mit schickem design
und maximaler mobilität so konnte ich
also egal wo ich war ob in der wohnung
zu besuch bei den eltern oder auch
natürlich im büro super arbeiten und
auch mega anspruchsvolle arbeiten
erledigen wie das rendern oder
modellieren der 300 hat mich das ganze
aber ehrlich gesagt nicht nachdem ich
den ersten blick auf die checkliste
dieses laptops geworfen in diesem
kleinen schmalen slitan ding befindet
sich ein intel core prozessor der zwölf
generation eine nvidia geforce rtx 30 80
mit 16 gb grafikspeicher
64 gigabyte ram eine ein terabyte ssd
und unheimlich vielen weiteren kranken
spex also egal für welchen
anwendungsbereich ihrem neuen laptop
sucht also gaming kreativ kam die uni
egal was bei msi werdet ihr definitiv
für mich schlägt dafür einfach auf den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
und checkt ms produkte aus also kein
witz das hat mich wirklich umgehauen ich
konnte komplett flüssig innerhalb von
ein paar sekunden die skills in sketchup
mit blu-ray also ich hab eigenes licht
gesetzt 3d kram gemacht modelliert und
ich habe ein paar sekunden das komplette
bildrändern können aus völlig verliebt
ist also ein riesen dankeschön an msi
fürs möglich machen dieses videos und
damit auch dieser videoreihe nur durch
so coole partner ist es mir möglichst so
große aufwendige und teure projekte zu
machen in super dankbar check die links
in video beschreibung ab und euch viel
spaß weiter mit dem
living eine firma aus den usa hat sich
komplett darauf spezialisiert
convertible gegenstände zu bauen
convertible einrichtungsgegenstände
betten schränke komplette studio
komplexe also richtig verrückten richtig
coolen kam der komplett elektrisch
funktioniert und ja es macht alles
keinen sinn so was in der mietwohnung zu
packen bewegliche teile bedeutenden
fehleranfälligkeit bedeutet dass es viel
eher kaputt gehen kann dass es falsch
bedient wird das ist einfach wenig
schlau so was in der mietwohnung zu
machen aber es ist auch gleichzeitig
fucking beides wenn dein bett einfach
hoch und runter fährt oder den
kleiderschrank rein und raus fährt und
deswegen könnte ich mir auch das sehr
gut vorstellen auch hier würde das bett
elektrisch in einen für ihn vorgesehenen
kasten fahren was ihnen vor koch dämpfen
schützt also ziemlich nice auch da eine
lösung um die küche und das bett im
selben raum zu haben und dazu gibt es
die möglichkeit sich bei dem
elektrischen bett dazwischen zu
entscheiden ob das bett hochfährt und
unten eine sofa fläche entsteht oder
esstisch auch das wieder ziemlich
perfekt weil ein möbelstück quasi zwei
zweck erfüllt für diese wohnung finde
ich eigentlich passender sich für das
bett mit dem sofa zu entscheiden fährt
das bett also hoch und das sofa entsteht
können wir den coffee table der vor dem
sofa steht so kaufen so bauen lassen das
auch daraus ein esstisch wird die
fehlenden zwei stühle würde ich einfach
ganz offen im raum an die wand hängen
genau so wie wir es im alten büro hatten
was ich ziemlich stylish und irgendwie
auch super praktisch findet außerdem
sind diese standard klappstühle richtig
bequem haben die tatsächliche anderthalb
jahre bei uns im büro genutzt und waren
super happy damit dadurch dass das bett
dann nicht mehr an die wand klappt wie
ein plan eins hätten wir mehr platz um
die kirche zu erweitern richtig
ordentlich zu erweitern um genau zu sein
um ein meter fünfzig und man hätte eine
richtig große ordentliche küchenzeile in
der man vielleicht sogar gründe platz
finden würde um eine spülmaschine zu
integrieren oder sogar eine
waschmaschine was die problematik aus
video 1 aus dem keller lösen will
allgemein sind meine beine noch nicht
besonders detailliert licht
beispielsweise ist mit diesem thema was
ich finde was irgendwie sachen direkt
mit eingebaut sein muss also
beispielsweise in den einbauschrank ich
möchte eine smarte lichtlösung die aber
keine smart home lösung ist weil ich
finde das smarthome sachen häufig
verkompliziert was ich mir eher
vorstellen kann als irgendwas über 7 zu
steuern wäre licht was im einbauschrank
einfach aufgeht wenn man die tür
aufmacht quasi wie in den kühlschrank so
was finde ich deutlich cooler als dann
ipad steuerung hin zu bauen
lichtschalter ist ein lichtschalter und
der funktioniert unheimlich gut und
meiner meinung nach besser als alles
über serie oder alexa zu steuern was
mich in den letzten jahren schon
ziemlich aufgeregt hat um diese sachen
dann wirklich ins detail auszuarbeiten
brauche ich wahrscheinlich noch eine
innenarchitektin dann brauche ich
wahrscheinlich noch einen tischler der
das alles ohne anfertigen kann brauche
ich noch einen elektriker brauche ich
noch ein bauer mit denen ich das
natürlich gerne alles zusammen machen
will die aber das knowledge haben um mir
sagen zu können was geht was nicht
ich melde mich zurück aus mallorca
vorweg vielen vielen dank ist
unglaublich wie hochqualitativ und wie
viele pläne eingereicht wurden also ich
habe scheinbar wirklich viele
innenarchitekten oder architekten in
einer community ich muss mich aber
leider entscheiden und habe mich für
vier pläne entschieden die ihr jetzt
gleich zur auswahl haben werdet und die
ich euch vorstellen weil allerdings so
viele pläne eingereicht wurden und so
viele gute pläne eingereicht wurden bin
ich mir überlegen ob ich bis zum
nächsten video website online stelle wo
ich alle anderen pläne auch noch aus
stelle die mir richtig gut gefallen
haben und mit den leuten die sie
eingereicht haben kontaktdaten
austauschen oder austauschen ob sie ihre
kontaktdaten online haben wollen damit
ihr vielleicht einen passenden
architekten für euch aus meiner
community finden könnt und die leute
auch was davon haben außerdem wurden
paar raumkonzepte häufiger eingereicht
als andere was dafür spricht dass
mehrere leute denken das ist schlau wäre
das einzurichten eingeschlossen mir und
deswegen habe ich probiert diese
raumaufteilung hier auch in der auswahl
zu featuren am ende werdet ihr über und
straw poll in der video beschreibung
abstimmen können und entscheiden wer von
diesen einreichung 1000 euro gewinnt wir
starten tube in sleep von leon
unheimlich geile idee die tatsächlich
auch nur einmal so in der form kam er
hat sich dazu entschieden in den raum
quasi einen kasten zu bauen in dem alles
vereint wird schlafen wohnen stauraum
und so weiter und so sieht das ganze aus
ich bin leer und 21 jahre aus wie nun
will gerade mit meinem bachelor interior
design fertig geworden das sieht man das
sieht wunderbar aus und hat mich richtig
geflasht schreibtisch bett schränke und
stauraum werden 1 dies spart platz und
liefert der wohnung jede menge platz der
club öffnet sich der fensterfront und
bringt licht an alle ecken der wohnung
die freie blickachse vom eingang zur
fensterfront ist zusätzlicher
lichtspender das sehen wir auch hier im
grundriss links geht's rein ins bad die
küche schließt direkt ans bad an mega
geil weil da liegen alle anschlüsse und
dann gibt's arbeitsbereiche stauraum das
bett und neben dem bett zur fensterfront
nochmal eine möglichkeit dort zu sitzen
und quasi in den wohnbereich zu haben
das ganze wurde dann auch noch in
verschiedenen farben ein bisschen heller
design das ganze sieht super krass nach
einem hotelzimmer aus was ich aber in
der wohnung eigentlich ziemlich geil
finde und dieser plan hat mich
tatsächlich ziemlich geflasht also tube
in sleep von leon ist option nummer eins
community wettbewerb einreichung von
martha wigger ist option nummer zwei
sieht mega geil aus die aufmachung der
pdf ist mega mega geil und der plan noch
viel besser beim reinkommen das
badezimmer da wo er hingehört und an das
badezimmer schließt dann nicht die küche
an sondern eine schlaf nische und brennt
dadurch quasi die schlafmütze vom raum
ab ohne das ist ein eigener raum werden
muss was ich mega mega geil v im
eingangsbereich gibt es eine garderobe
mit stauraum die aber nicht der einzige
steuerung ist dazu komme ich gleich noch
mal wenn wir nämlich weiter durch den
flur am bett vorbeigehen kommen wir in
einen komplett offenen lebe und
wohnbereich zum essen arbeiten sachen
verstauen und der küche und das ist
alles in einem das bedeutet wir kommen
durch den flur laufen richtung fenster
rein und haben den riesigen offenen
wohnbereich und das badezimmer kann so
groß bleiben wie es ist nicht so wie bei
mir wo ich es deutlich kleiner gemacht
haben auch die renderings sehen mega
mega gut aus und ich habe euch natürlich
alle pdfs einmal in die video
beschreibung gepackt ihr euch das alles
noch mal genauer angucken und durchlesen
könnt um eine wirklich weise
entscheidung zu treffen für welchen plan
ihr denn wollten möchtet unter den
ganzen einbauschränken im bodenbereich
befindet sich weiterhin stauraum und das
ist nämlich auch der große vorteil an
einbaumöbel wir entscheiden uns einmal
wo gesessen wird und dann können wir den
kompletten platz unter den
sitzmöglichkeiten daneben für stauraum
und so weiter nutzen also mag vielen
vielen dank dem plan hat mich auch sehr
geflasht und ist eine würdige zweite
option in dieser abstimmung option
nummer 3 von markus wir haben einen
grundriss der dem von martha
grundsätzlich so ein bisschen ähnlich
sieht anstatt der garderobe im
eingangsbereich befindet sich dort aber
die küche was ziemlich cool ist weil wir
dann die anschlüsse eben benutzen können
das bett ist aber genau dort wo marta
ist auch platziert hat und wir schaffen
eben auch einen offenen wohnbereich vor
dem fenster und nun wirklich offenen
raum also da konnte ich mich sehr
schlecht entscheiden eigentlich wollte
ich nur einen plan nehmen wo das bett
genau an dieser stelle ist aber die
positionierung der küche hat es mir
wirklich schwer gemacht zu entscheiden
und ich überlasse ich die entscheidung
auch hier die renderings mega mega geil
wir haben ein offenen flur an der küche
vorbei in den offenen wohn und
arbeitsbereich also tatsächlich ein
unheimlich guter plan und soweit ich das
als laie einschätzen kann
ich bin wirklich richtig fleisch von dem
ganzen plänen die eingereicht wurden es
war super schwer zu entscheiden was sich
über alle pläne zieht was sie auch über
mein plan gezogen hat wir müssen mit
einbau optionen arbeiten also wir müssen
den schrank fest installieren wir müssen
das alles raumhoch machen dürfen
wirklich keinen zentimeter in der
planung verlieren genau das hat markus
hier auch nicht getan und das sieht
einfach unheimlich gut aus am ende ist
wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen präferenz
ob man die küche er vom bett abgetrennt
haben möchte oder sie mit in den
wohnbereichen integrieren möchte es gibt
aber vielleicht auch noch eine option
wie wir es wirklich räumlich abtrennen
können ohne eine statische abtrennung zu
haben und damit zum nächsten und letzten
planen entweder oder von melvin man muss
sich nämlich vielleicht gar nicht
konkret entscheiden wie der raum
aufgeteilt sein muss wenn man die
raumaufteilung nachträglich noch ändern
kann und genau darum dreht sich dieser
plan beim reinkommen links das bad
wunderbar die küche schließt tanz bat an
wegen alle anschlüsse und der
einbauschrank der jetzt gerade in der
wohnung ist kann quasi dort bleiben wo
er ist der witz ist aber wir haben keine
türen die auf schwenken sondern eine
schiebetür die entweder die küche zu
viel oder den schrank zu fährt was ich
ziemlich neues findet das bett wurde
auch anders positioniert und zwar direkt
unter den fenstern was ich auch eine
richtig coole option finde weil man dann
einfach immer schön mit den
sonnenstrahlen morgens aufwachen kann
der wird es aber es wurde nicht einfach
ein bett hingestellt sondern es soll ein
plateau in die wohnung gebaut werden die
dann extra stauraum liefert zum einen
ist der stauraum über schubladen und
ausziehen möglichkeiten zu erreichen und
zum anderen durch herausnehmbare
bodenplatten um quasi auch in die letzte
ecke des stauraums zu kommen in diesem
plateau ist aber auch direkt der
arbeitsbereich und essbereich mit
integriert und wir können quasi diese
eine einbau option in drei oder vier
verschiedenen optionen nutzen eine
unglaublich gute option finde ich gerade
weil wir das bett einfach in eine ecke
des raumes schieben nicht wie in meinem
plan mit dem release im bett einfach in
die mitte des raumes was eigentlich
quatsch mit soße ist weil wir müssen uns
mit dem bett eigentlich am besten
orientieren um uns den raum halt eben
nicht zu zu stellen es ist einfach ein
absoluter traum ich kann mich gar nicht
entscheiden ich weiß wirklich nicht
welche optionen da die beste ist und
deswegen überlasse ich euch die
entscheidung und damit auch die
entscheidung wer der zuschauer welcher
der pläne 1000 euro mit nach hause
nehmen soll über die video beschreibung
kommt ihr direkt zur abstimmung könnte
dort abstimmen da sind auch noch mal die
links zu allen plänen die euch nochmal
genau anschauen könnt und auch noch mal
ein bisschen genauer lesen könnt was die
leute dazu geschrieben haben und ein
bisschen mehr erklärung was für ein
unheimlich geiles projekt ich danke dass
ihr das video bis hierhin angeschaut
habt ich bedanke mich vielmals natürlich
auch bei msi die dieses video und das
gesamte projekt unterstützt haben und
mir die möglichkeit geben auch von
mallorca aus vernünftig an dem projekt
weiterarbeiten zu können dank dieses
laptops checkt msi unbedingt über den
link in der video beschreibung applus
dem video und lag damit euch gefallen
hat vergesse ich den kanal zu abonnieren
um keines der folgenden videos dieses
projektes zu verpassen vergesst nicht
abzustimmen und wir sehen uns in den
nächsten tagen wieder und ich danke euch
jemals dass so viele leute von euch
coole pläne eingeschickt haben und ihr
es mir so schwer gemacht hat mich für
ein paar pläne zu entscheiden cous cous
cous
[Musik]